That was my next point is obviously
those letters are on the intranet.
So I was able to read them that various
professors and a certain um,
faculty,
um,
had signed.
And
because you're tenured in many ways
that's a,
that's a very strong safety net.
But do you ever have those moments where
you really feel like they are,
that you,
that there is a very strategic attempt
to demonize you and to isolate you in
the university as much as possible
almost to the point that you would,
God forbid it feel like you needed to
leave or resign?
Well,
I think that my job actually was in
danger for about three months in,
in the year ago when all of this broken,
the diversity didn't really know what to
do.
I think that they got themselves
together by December and then I went
back teaching in January and that went
very well.
I've had zero negative interactions with
students.
None and no negative interactions with
faculty members or administrators for
that matter?
Like not personally.
I think that there's a coterie of
people,
um,
the women and Gender Studies Institute,
for example,
in and of course all the people whose
disciplines I've vilified.
Yeah.
And rightly so in my estimation because
I don't regard them as disciplines.
There are pseudo disciplines and they're
corrupting the university and more than
the university.
So I feel no compunctions whatsoever
about what I've said about those
disciplines.
I think there,
I don't,
it's,
I would be hard pressed to say anything
good about the whatsoever.
Um,
and of course,
and I've,
I've really gone after the Ontario
Institute of Studies of Education.
I think I've referred to it repeatedly
as a rat's nest central,
which I really believe,
I think it's an unbelievably dangerous
organization.
And so it's not surprising that people
are,
especially the people who were
associated with those areas are not
happy about me,
but,
um,
that's okay.
They can be unhappy about me.
That's not a problem.
Um,
yeah,
I think that'll change,
but I don't think they have any ability
whatsoever to move me from my position.
I think the faculty is,
like a month ago,
the Faculty Association wrote a letter
to the university condemning me because
of this website I had talked about
making,
um,
which I'm still toying with.
I,
I'm redesigning it to her.
I think I'm going to set it up so that
they will identify non postmodern
courses instead of identifying
postmodern courses.
I think that's a better tack.
And uh,
but you know,
they,
they accused me of setting up a hate
list of doxing and all sorts of
ridiculous things,
but it's just not getting any traction.
Serena,
it's,
it was almost inevitable.
The,
you know,
as you became more popular in your
videos are being watched by millions and
your reach,
and they're scaremongering tactics
haven't worked that they would actually
resort to some more desperate measures
to vilify you.
And I think the latest thing they found
was this website that you're planning.